we got to the Future verse I wondered
when that would come
[Music]
up well hello everyone um I'm Harriet
Johnson
and I'm delighted to welcome you to this
wree future verse event here at the
McLaren Technology Center the future
verse is where white tree brings
together ideas conversations and
insights around our vision to build a
world where wealth is defined by how you
live not what you own recently we've
been thinking about something we call
the Conformity crisis in our current
Society it feels like we're finding it
harder than ever to have open
conversations as our fear of getting
things wrong grows So today we're
talking to someone who has extensive
experience in having difficult
conversations the first thing I have to
acknowledge uh is that I do my job not
out of a sense of social obligation not
in order to make the world a better
place but because I love doing it and I
have a natural inclination to go to
places where people think differently
than I do and especially where that
involves some kind of moral quality that
I find questionable people who are used
to call weird like weird weekends I
don't love the word weird first of all
it feels judgmental second of all it
feels inexact like one man's weird is
another person's completely normal right
weirdness is to some extent in the eyes
of the beholder nevertheless the people
I speak to are quite weird and um I know
little contradictory but I think and I
think what it has to do with this is a
sort of sense of um them being either
loggerheads with the wider World by
violating so certain social norms they
work in Industries like like the sex
industry or they're involved in
extremism or or or religious groups that
feel like they're on the edge of society
they they're apocalyptic in their
thinking and or they're a loog ahe heads
with themselves because of choices
they've made so in some sort of sense of
social angst the qu the question was why
do I think it's important to do that
because after the fact having done it
having done it because I enjoyed doing
it I've realized there's real value in
it and I think what it comes down to is
about is challenging patterns of
behavior that you have thinking about
the world in a different way I mean for
me a lot of the pleasure of it is just
actually reminding myself that my life
as complicated and and sort of fraught
as it seems at times is less complicated
and fraught than the people I'm among
but I also think in practicing habits of
Tolerance of listening of understanding
you can open up the world to a different
way of thinking and that you know that
we can all and and these qualities that
you can that you can think about things
in a different way you can connect in
unlikely ways with people who you might
think have nothing in common with you
and and thereby the world seems a
friendlier place the what I sometimes
say if I can put it in a nutshell is the
weirdest thing about weird people is how
normal they
are and that wherever you go wherever
whatever extreme it may be whether
physically or in terms of ideology
you'll be more surprised by the
commonalities you find than by the
differences as much as I'd like to think
that I have techniques and that I I'm
kind of This brilliant um that I'm sort
of brilliant at adopting strategies for
connection really I'm I'm I a lot of
what I do in so far as it connects with
people is unsort like is actually things
that I come by by accident and are
probably qualities that in another
setting I might wish I didn't have I
actually think that my certainly when I
started a c insecurity a certain sense
of
awkwardness almost felt like disarming
you know and I wasn't like oh I'm not
pretending to be awkward you know I
wasn't Li what I need is some glasses
like some ill-fitting um clothes like I
I'll make sure there's like a little bit
of you know just Rumple like make sure
my jeans are a bit rumpled my shoes look
a bit you know like they've seen better
days it was very much the case that I
just had I was just being who I was and
that that was you I didn't have a great
wardrobe and I was really worried
starting out when I worked for Michael
Moore I just thought this is a nightmare
I've been given a network TV job on NBC
in America you know with no TV
experience it was an you know I just
thought this is this is a disaster you
know I'm going to go out there and I'm
going to make a complete fool of myself
and and and I was just I was frightened
I was fright when I went on that first
story that I did which was about
apocalyptic Cults um around around the
US I just thought how am I this they've
got the wrong guy and um and I think in
but but adventitiously if that's a word
I'll look that up later um
adventitiously uh what turned out to be
the case was those those qualities that
I thought were disabilities actually
ended up softening people up it's e it's
and and and inv you know it's like by
being a little awkward it invites the
person in a bit more anyway I'm just
trying you know what is realness it's
just by being a bit real and and and I
know that sounds really basic and
probably banal but by being a bit real
and actually showing up and not making
it like how am I going to get the best
out of this person how am I going to
close the sale how am I going to you
actually just go in there think like I
really hope this person you know likes
me I hope this I hope this person um if
I I hope I can kind of make this run
smoothly and connect with this person
and and and that that realness infuses
every part of the
conversation so you've handled a lot of
tricky sensitive topics and here at wree
we focus on having open conversations
about money which could be considered
probably one of the last taboo subjects
that there is especially in British
culture I'm not sure how different it is
in American culture so how easy do you
find it to talk about money how you
spend it and is that something that's
come up in your career one of the most
recent films I did in America was about
the rap scene in Florida where it's
quite difficult to have a conversation
that's not about money right in fact to
carry a huge wedge of of of of of
dollars or like $100 bills like that and
press it against your head is one of the
cliches of the genre right you literally
will have jewelry around your wrist
around your neck designed to advertise
how much money you have and a great ice
breaker should you find yourself in Fort
Lauderdale or Miami interviewing a
SoundCloud rapper or a gangster rapper
is um I love your jewelry like how much
did it cost and and they'll be very
happy to tell you and the you know I was
you know I was 100 G's I don't even know
if G's is the right term forgive me for
my slang but um and the conversation
will proceed very smoothly from there
and I think in America am in general
probably uh the money conversation is
less taboo right I think that it's
interesting but only up to a point and I
think it's interesting in so far as
other people find it interesting it's
interesting once you you know once you
have enough money right then it becomes
a source of relief you have the freedom
to not really worry so much anymore
right to not worry about whether you're
going to make your rent or be able to
pay your bills and you know there is
decisions that then take place about how
you make sure you don't lose your money
what you do with your money what portion
of that money you should be um donating
towards good causes and otherwise how
much you need to set aside for your
family all of those are very personal
decisions and probably worthy of a
program in its own right and certainly
like a a a responsible company that
could advise you on how to make those
decisions that would be a brilliant idea
but um I think for me for me it's like
it's a measure and talk to Stuart after
the presentation um for me it's about uh
I I'm interested in metrics of um of of
of how people consider what's important
in life and and metrics of you know
what's interesting to me is like if n
Rogers says he has 500 million but he's
not happy right he seemed very happy by
the way and and and and and and stresses
and the psychological issues that come
along with you know positive and
otherwise that come along with the
decisions that go with having a lot of
money I you know so my tip for listening
we were talking a bit about this
beforehand is is is just to find someone
something that you're interested in but
it's very hard for me to advise on that
because there's a sense which it comes
so naturally to me like I just like
hiding I like the feeling of
invisibility that you get when you're
talking to someone and they're just
downloading whatever is in their head
does that make and I again this may be
too much information but when I was
growing up my big worry was like God I
don't think I'm very interesting because
I don't have opinions about anything and
I'd much rather listen to what other
people have to say and you know that's
changed as as life has gone on but I
genuinely do
find um other people's perspectives
fascinating and and I do find that the
world's such a strange and in many
respects a lonely place and that by by
finding someone and connecting with them
and realizing that in unlikely ways you
can you just find you just sometimes it
takes a little work but with a little
bit of digging you find oh the person's
recently gone through a divorce or
they're bereaved or they were an orphan
and they were adopted and and there
there's some fascinating part of life
that you get to and and and that you can
learn from and that makes you feel a
little bit more at home in the world
[Music]
really